[Music]
what's up folks Dave Ramsey here and
you're listening to real estate the
Ramsey way I'm excited for this episode
because we're talking about how to build
wealth in real estate investing in real
estate's a Hot Topic these days and if
you do it right you can make some real
money I'm personally a big fan of using
investment properties to earn income and
to build wealth it's something I
personally love to do but before you
jump SP feet first here's a few things
you need to know about using real estate
to build wealth otherwise you can make
some major mistakes with a lot of zeros
on the end of them and trust me I've
done that so stick around to get answers
to some common questions about real
estate
investing so I did my first
flip in
1983 the year before I was born so that
would be 30 years ago right or 40 years
ago 40 years 40 years ago 40 years ago
40 years ago yeah the first flip I did I
was so stupid that I thought that
everything that was a
foreclosure was a good buy that if it
said foreclosure that it must be cheap I
equated foreclosure with cheap which
sometimes is true I think most people do
but I bought a a HUD repo they used to
put them in the newspaper and you would
bid on them FHA re re FHA foreclosures
HUD repo out of the news you had a
newspaper is a bid process I turned in
the bid I talked to Banker into
financing 100% of it because I had a
real estate degree I was a real estate
guy I knew all about real estate and I
was 23 years old so I was a freaking
genius okay and so I bought this house
um I knew everything about the house
before I bought it I'd gone through it
with the fine tooth comb okay the um in
those days they used uh we we used uh uh
copper pipes for the water supply and
the co the house had been sitting empty
and so the copper pipes had Frozen and
split and so it was pretty much a
sprinkler system
underneath uh and you had to go through
and redo the copper pipes and I knew how
to do that cuz I'd done Renovations work
in high school working for my dad in
real estate business so I crawled around
on my little back under there with a
little torch and fixed all of spliced
all these pipes fixed all the pipes uh
put new carpet in it went in on the week
and Shar and I repainted it okay and I
kept all of my receipts for what I spent
and paid myself zero labor okay stupid I
was and we put the house on the market
and it's sold in five weeks so I'm a
huge
success net net net when I got done I
added up what we had in it what we paid
for the closing cost what we paid on the
closing cost on the
resale what actual after every dollar is
recorded what actual net profit that I
make
$842 you're an overnight success I'm now
a game on can't nobody tell I'm
obviously good at
this which means that I probably paid
myself what a dollar an hour labor yeah
well you know I didn't get paid for the
labor the 842 was with this free labor I
had I had slave labor me yeah you my and
my wife yeah so we're in there so that
was job one okay the next one I I bought
and I thought well I'm not buying any
houses in bad neighborhoods cuz I don't
know anything about all that stuff I'll
get in trouble but this guy called me up
and he had a house and he sold it to me
for
$7,000 and I ran the what I thought was
the estimate and I had three contractors
look at it and give us bids MH and uh
the first contractor wanted a $1,500
deposit up front never saw him again
right went to his trailer and knocked on
the door in the trailer park trying to
get my wonder I wonder I didn't get shot
by the way he had already left and gone
to cazo or wherever it is contractors go
when they take your $1500 cuz you're an
idiot and you give it to him up front
yeah and so then I started on the
second contractor the third contractor
the fourth contractor and uh when I
finished with that property it I had
already done a whole bunch of other
deals by then uh like uh 60 or 80 more
deals oh my gosh by the time I finished
that property I ended up only losing
$144,000 on a house I paid $7,000 for 4
and2 years later oh my gosh this is how
dumb I am so if that had wait if that
second house had been your first house I
would have been out of business I would
have been Nate yeah you would have been
like I'm never doing this my wife would
have been going yeah instead I managed
to delay the pain on that one meanwhile
doing a whole bunch of others and I made
a lot of money yeah I made a lot of
money I ended up in in my life I have
owned over 2,000 pieces of real estate I
flipped real estate as my job for four
years buy I was using 90day notes to fix
them and flip them I made and I started
buying property at70 cents on the dollar
minus
repairs wow so a $100,000 property I buy
it for 70 minus the repairs that was the
formula and that means I bought a lot of
foreclosures a lot of Estates I did some
historic rehabs we've done a bazillion
deals I can walk around Nashville and
say I did that house that house that
house that house 30 40 years later I
want to take that tour and uh now you
don't want to be in that neighborhood
probably but um okay some of those
neighborhoods are now gentrified but um
got you yeah they've come back a long
way from $7,000 now it's 260 to live on
that street and it's a great property
not really still in Dodge City they
shoot up and down the street if it's
Dodge City I don't care whether it's
gentrified or not so anyway the uh
you're killing me here but yeah so this
is this is my real estate career so when
I get aggravated at the idiots on Tic
Tac it's because I was one of them yeah
okay I was doing the exact same stuff
and I can
smell
neophyte beginner a mile away because I
was I was I was 23 I was going to get
rich in real estate I made $842 minus
the cost of my labor I lost $14,000 and
then I went on to make money and make
money I started figuring it out that I
had to you know had to I had to had to
be tough with contractors I had to get
with good ones and and I had to have be
tough on schedules you had to be
finished and then you put the house on
the market aggressively and you flip it
you don't keep it ever and uh you know
not like her we're not in the rental
business and then I then I ended up
buying a bunch of property I buy
packages of houses and I buy 10 or 20 at
once and they were rental portfolio and
I I lost every bit of that when I went
bankrupt in uh in in 19
88 five years later I had now I had $4
million wor real estate when we went in
that's a fast went in bankruptsy yeah
that's a whirlwind Dave it was I worked
all the time and I was really really
good at doing deals but I'm saying to go
from zero to hero or hero to zero and
back Zero to Hero to zero that's a PhD
in Du MB is what that is yeah and so but
I got a lifetime of learning there and
it led me to have a bull craap meter
that is very sensitive to real estate
people and uh so you know when you guys
are talking about real estate real
estate real estate real estate cuz real
estate's real hot right it's a popular
fad topic again everybody wants to do a
real estate deal everybody wants to do a
flip everybody wants to own a real
estate renters will pay your rent
renters will pay the payment you don't
worry about it says people who've never
had renters that's a dumb butt statement
okay let me tell you let me teach you
some words Chapter
13 Bankruptcy for I will pay you when by
God I want to okay and let me tell you
what you can do with a tenant who's in a
bankruptcy nothing wow you have a stay
on you which is an injunction a federal
court has looked at you like a dog and
said stay and as a creditor if you even
call your tenant you can be held in
contempt of court you cannot talk to
them you cannot do anything except
everything they wish as far as repairs
while they pay zero rent cuz you stay
dog
stay yeah you learn this when you've had
a couple of them so when renters are
always they're going to pay the payment
and it's a free house and I'm I know I I
have a jet airplane and you're just an
idiot you're just an idiot on Tik Tok
that's what you are it's
unbelievable so real real estate is
great but you there's a people factor
with the contractors there's a people
factor with the renters there's a people
Factor when I overestimate how what the
uh how how much money I'm going to make
I underestimate the contractor the time
it's going to take to run it I I I I
think it's going to sell faster than it
is cuz I'm always a glass half full guy
and right before that's when you get
your freaking nose blooded slow down
people pay cash for this stuff and run
it like a business not like a get-rich
quick scheme it's your only hope of
doing making money in real estate cat is
with us in Pittsburgh hey cat Welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hi Dave how are you today thank you
for having me my honor what's
up um yes I just wanted to give you a
little bit of background about me um I'm
married currently we just got M Mark and
I just got married on May 7th and um we
are currently debt free um thank the
Lord and um we have approximately um
about 70 to 80k in liquid and we make
collectively right around 70 to 7 5
yearly and what we are doing right now
is we're renting an apartment so with
our rental um renting utilities our
expenses are right around 850 to 900 a
month um and right now uh we do have
some crypto Investments and we'd really
like to get into retail um I'm sorry
real estate investment as well but we're
not sure if maybe either moving into a
duplex for our first home would be the
right choice as far as
um you know having a place to move into
and obviously making some investment on
the other side of that duplex or if
maybe we should like buy a smaller home
fix it up and within a year's time maybe
move out of that to another one and then
just rent that home out or flip it um
but that's what we want to ask you
okay well I think a uh a precursor to
the answer is uh the rule that we use at
ramsy is we give you we answer your
questions of what we would do knowing
what we
know if we woke up in your
shoes okay and um I by the time I
started with nothing and by the time I
was 26 I bought $4 million wor of real
estate I was doing flip this house
before chip and Joanna were
born okay literally I mean I'm not
kidding it was the early 80s right and
um no disrespect to them but because
they're wonderful but the uh um you know
and uh I I was using short-term notes to
borrow money to flip the house and make
a profit I made a profit on almost every
deal I did and I still went
broke because the bank got nervous and
called all our notes at one time and
there's a word we use for Real Estate
that sells really fast
cheap so we ended up selling the real
estate for less than it was owed on it
which was way less than it was worth to
keep foreclosures from happening and it
broke me and I lost everything in my 20s
okay so that's who's answering your
question I by the way do love real
estate I own several hundred million
dollars worth of real estate today but
after that I quit borrowing
money and so that's the guy and the
place that you called to get your
question answered you need to know that
it's In fairness okay so if you want to
do flip this house with money uh
borrowed money and all that kind of
stuff you're really on the wrong show
you're not going to do what we tell you
to
do okay so having said all that
uh you know here's my answer on duplexes
as your first property and then here's
my answer what we would do if we woke up
in your shoes uh the beautiful thing
about a duplex is your renter lives next
door the problem with a duplex is your
renter lives next
door can you tell I've been there okay
so if they want something they can knock
on your door but you also don't have
much trouble collecting the rent cuz
they're right there cars in the driveway
you know and so we're going to get our
money we have to wait on some uh thing
to happen and so it's a you have to set
some relational emotional boundaries if
you're going to do that that's the
problem it's not that bad the biggest
issue I had with duplexes and I've owned
I don't know uh probably a hundred of
them is that the uh typically are rental
properties and so typically the buyer
when you get ready to resell them is
another
investor who's looking for a deal the
buyer when you get ready to sell that
same square footage of house as a duplex
in a single family is a cute little
couple that wants a picket fence and a
place for their French Bulldog to run
around feels like a personal attack yeah
it was a personal attack George just
take it for what it is and they're
willing to pay more like
retail and so single family homes of the
same square footage within a two block
area will go up faster in value than
duplexes will because of who your pool
of buyer future buyers are in general
now a nice duplex will outperform a
lousy single family neighborhood I'm not
talking about I'm talking about Apples
to Apples comparison
okay so if you could find a really cool
duplex in an upand cominging sweet reg
gentrified neighborhood might be a real
seriously good play right versus buying
a dumpy single family okay so that
that's your upsides and downsides on
duplexes what would I do if I woke up in
your shoes and George I'll let you chime
in after personal attack but the
uh is I would pay cash for my first home
as soon as I can and you're very close
to doing that once you have decided you
don't like losing 50% of your money in
Bitcoin and so um how much do you guys
have in crypto just
curious um well since we just got
married we haven't merged all that yet I
really don't know how much he has I have
approximately Just sh I have 10 grand
okay okay you guys are much you like
Risk more than I do but I've been
broke that's another thing you need to
keep in mind I I'm I don't like Risk
much I don't like losing money I lost a
bunch of it and it's too hard to make I
don't like losing it so and and I know
that because you're playing with um
Lottery money over there crypto's you
know you've lost your butt on it and um
and all and standing around acting like
you did something cool you know it's
just it's it's it's horrible so I'd be
getting out of that I'd be buying some
real estate pay cash for George yeah I
mean you guys don't have a home
currently right primary residence so
that would be my first goal I wouldn't
mess with the duplex and plus they're
really hard to find right now because
you're not the only one who had this
awesome idea and so if I'm you I'm
getting into a primary residence with
the money you have put a strong down
payment down work on paying that off as
soon as possible and then man the world
is your oyster pay cash what I did after
I went broke cat was I got my house paid
off took me a little while then I saved
up I paid cash for my first rental
not the sexiest answer though you know
what happens you know what happens with
a rental that you have zero debt on it
cash flows like a
bandit it starts just stacking money up
and able to pay cash for the second one
fairly quick and you got two of them
sitting there with zero payments you're
just stacking
money and you can buy the third one then
you're just stacking money and ever
since then I've been just stacking money
and then I have some idiot walk up to me
and go you're so lucky luck didn't have
squat to do with it duber I used a
system and a process you know but Dave
the renters going to pay my mortgage no
they don't because renters don't always
pay can you say
pandemic can you say eviction
moratorium yeah
yeah yeah you can't get them out and you
know what I had some people that were
had some serious problems during Co and
I could be gentle as a landlord cuz you
don't need them the money cuz I didn't
have to have the money to eat you know I
had one had cancer I don't throw
somebody's got cancer in the street I'm
not
heartless surveys show that most
Americans think real estate is a great
long-term investment and I agree but
it's a big commitment that involves a
lot of time money risk and hard work so
you don't want to go into this thing
blind but you can learn more about the
types of investment properties how to
get started and how to make money in
real estate just check out the Link in
the show notes or go to ramsy
solutions.com
realestateinvesting Nate is an Austin
Texas hi Nate welcome to the Ramsey
Show appreciate it sure what's up so I'm
trying to find out have about 12 years
of trying to convince my wife to let me
buy a flip house finally convinced her
after saving up about $50,000 to do so
and she didn't want to do it but she
made me promise I wouldn't uh try to
rent it out that we would sell it at the
end of it after a 3-month uh
construction duration That was supposed
to be this was this was back in November
of 21 I bought it and we're now a year
and a half later that three months has
turned into a year and a half and
finally after three three contractors
got the house finished and put it on the
market in April and it's been on the
market for a little over 60 days now
with showing or two every other week or
every week and no offers or anything
like that I've dropped the price from
240 down to
217 and still not seeing much more
movement so this is harder than they say
on Tik Tock
huh much harder with the residential
contractors it's a different different
how much have you lost now all the
idiots on Tik Tok have to use
residential contractors too yeah yeah
agreed yeah yeah this oh it's easy I got
$57 million in 20 minutes and mhm bunch
of crap okay how much of your I'm so
sorry Nate I've been right where you are
and it ain't no fun go ahead I'm sorry
say no I want to know how much he's lost
no he hadn't lost anything yet sold it
he hadn't sold itre I still still have
it and haven't sold it yet and I'm do
you have a mortgage on that
property so I have a helck on my my
personal property my my own home and
I've paid for paid cash for the rest of
it so I've got 157,000 in the helac that
I owe and then the rest was paid in cash
yeah and I'm I'm in it to at 221 right
now so I'm estimating with realtor fees
and closing costs it'll be about 241 um
that I'll be all
in but you're on the market for
217 correct So you you're going to lose
money yeah definitely going to lose
money for sure okay all right and
because you miss you messed your
estimates up uh and your contractor
choices up and and so your construction
cost was way above what you originally
planned in your pro fora well no my Pro
fora actually was uh
227 was what I was estimating to get
then the market went way up and then it
went way down well it didn't go way down
but it's for some reason it's just not
selling the house there's a house three
three story or three houses down that's
selling for 260 and it's it's on the
market for 260 and it's 200 ft less than
this one so why hasn't your you should
be giving yours away at 217 why are
people not crawling all over it the
Austin Market's not that dead is the
work is the workmanship not good well
it's it's about an hour outside of
Austin it's not in Austin um if the
house down the street is worth 260 and
you have yours at 200 square fet Less on
the mark 200 feet more on the market for
217 someone should have snur up in a
heartbeat I would have thought the same
thing my realtor said that the the comps
when we were going through this was
between 217 and 238 is what the comps
were other realtors that have come
through said it's a great price point at
225 and and now I've dropped it down
even more so I don't know why it's not
selling but I'm trying to figure out at
this point do I I've got about
$50,000 in cash that's not going to or
in Investments that are not going to
have a penalty if I take it out so I'm
trying to figure out do I pay down the
helck and just wait wait it out or the
hel is independent of this decision it's
on your
home you could sell this house for $10
and you still got the
helck well I would pay I would yeah I'm
just saying the interest rate in your
mind only are they connected well he's
just trying to think I don't want to
lose more money on interest having this
loan sit around I know correct okay so
the F the the all right number one you
need to get um jump online at Ramsey
Solutions and get in touch with a Ramsey
trusted endorsed local provider real
estate agent and have them come out and
look at it because they're someone
that's going to have at least three
years of experience and they will have
moved hundreds of units not tens of
units and they will be able to give you
some insight and you may want to change
real estate agents again um so first
thing because the numbers you're giving
me don't make sense you the the a house
does not vary as much as it has in this
conversation in value why why have they
given you any what you would call
negative feedback as to why why there's
the variance there or why it hasn't
sold so she's still saying that we're
we're within the right range um the only
there isn't anything like the house
looks good there's no concerns about the
house itself the neighborhood is up and
coming there's a lot of new builds the
house that's 260 was a new build mine
was a full renovation um so that's a
little bit of a difference yeah they're
not not it's not a little bit of a
difference it's a completely different
product they're not comparables
you wouldn't use a new build as a comp
for a renovated old house they're not
comps so your earlier comparison doesn't
even hold water bad bad analysis okay so
yeah I I think you need to get some help
and
look truly go to Ramsey Solutions and
check out Ramsey trusted person have
them look at it this is what I would
personally do and then based on what
they're telling me I'm I'm either going
to change Realtors and or I'm going to
drop the price be when you pay down the
HELOC you can do that in 3 months four
months 5 months if you need to or you
can sell this house I'm going to keep
lowering this house I mean if you got to
drop it at 195 and get it gone get it
gone because here's the thing you have
gone to the school of life and you are
paying some stupid tuition okay you did
not analyze or understand the
marketplace for contractors you do not
know how to hire or manage contractors
you do not know how to run a proforma on
a flip because you didn't have any
margin in your your flip your flip
needed to have another 25% margin that
it had you paid too much for this thing
going in considering the amount of work
you had to do to it because your your
your margin after you sell it is not
anything you're not making spit if your
contractors had worked well it would
didn't make spit and so you've got to go
back through and do an autopsy on why
this deal failed where you failed in the
process since you're going to pay $40 or
$50,000 for this lesson learn the lesson
in deta tail and the most painful lesson
of all is his wife going to say yep I
told you so I told you don't do this so
you did not put proper valuation on the
house you underestimated the cost and
you underestimated how hard it was to
deal with contractors and you
underestimated the time it was going to
take to flip it and you underestimated
that you were going to continue to be in
a white hot Market that's three things I
can tell right now you didn't know the
value you thought you did you didn't
know the heat of the market and you
thought you did and you don't know how
to deal with contractors and you thought
you did and you missed your estimates on
your construction and you thought you
did those four things combined are going
to cost you $ 30 or $40,000 before
you're done if you're lucky only that
but either way sell the thing get rid of
it dump you can pay off the home equity
loan then it's just a matter of how much
of your cash you're going to lose you're
going to net 150 so your home equity
loan's gone it's just a matter of how
much of your cash you're going to lose
then the last piece of this is this I
used to do crap like you
did only I did it to the tune of about
$4 million worth and it caused me to go
bankrupt Nate that's why I got no
patience for it because I was exactly
only I was successful at flipping them
and making a profit but I had a lot of
short-term notes and the banks called my
notes I was 28 years old and it
bankrupted me 30 years ago so I've
learned my lesson on doing flips with
anything but cash and I don't listen to
people like Tick Tac people that are
doing real estate seminars either I'm
done with it so those are the things I
learned the last one is this proverbs 31
says who can find a virtuous wife for
the heart of her hus for she is she is
more valuable than rubies for the heart
of her husband safely trusts her and he
will have no lack of gain I don't do
crap like this when my wife doesn't feel
good about it it costs me money every
time I
do Christian Is With Us in Greensboro
North Carolina hi Christian welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hey Dave uh yes uh so I was calling
because I had a question
I have uh $6 Million worth of uh
property here in the area and um I owe
almost $3 million about 2.8 million in
uh in loans uh my question was do you
think it's wise to sell some of my
portfolio to pay off the loans and be
debt free or should I utilize the
monthly cash flow to pay off the loans
uh fast what do you think well
congratulations you've done a good job
you got a good Equity position and
you've obviously got a going concern and
uh you there's a lot of different ways
to attack uh the situation where you are
you can keep doing more of what you've
been doing um here's what I learned when
I had uh when I was 25 years old 24
years old I had $4 million worth of real
estate and I owed 3 million on it so I
did not have as good an equity position
as you do okay I was about about 75%
loan to value you're about 50% all right
but uh I ended up losing everything
because the bank got sold to another
bank called our notes we had a lot of
flip notes out of 90-day notes and it
caught me and took me out and what I
learned from that going broke process in
my 20s 30 years ago was that uh those of
us that love real estate people like you
and me Christian uh sometimes we forget
to measure risk Common Sense tells you
and actual business business analysis
tells you that the more debt you have
the more risk you have would you agree
with that yes indeed okay and what I've
discovered now over 30 years not only of
teaching these things but of living a
completely debt-free life and I today on
several hundred million worth of real
estate um and uh what I've discovered in
that process building that portfolio a
different way over this 30 years is that
the lack of
risk with having no debt
has accelerated over the Long Haul the
amount of real estate I can own because
I don't make as many mistakes I don't
have setbacks I don't have cash flow
problems I've always got cash can you
imagine how much cash my real estate
throws off with no debt it's
obscene okay and uh so but and that
allow I can buy another piece of real
estate with just cash flow fairly often
it because we've got tremendous rents
coming in on these things now so all
that to say what I have learned from my
personal walk and from walking with
others is that where where I know you
will be the best off in 10 years and
have the most wealth because of the
lowered risk and the increased peace in
your life
um I is if you were debt free now do we
have to burn everything down and do this
suddenly because you just you and had a
conversation no I think you have a
gradual process and you say okay over a
year two years three years whatever it
is I'm going to move in that
direction because if I were in your
shoes I would rather have $4 million of
paid for Real Estate than $6 million of
real estate with $3 million worth of
debt very true and that's about where
you will be because your real estate
will go up in value while we're doing
this all right so how long You' been
doing this apparently you've been doing
it a while and you're good at at
it well I've been doing it since uh 2012
I actually used my W2 to uh help me
purchase property and I was also
flipping at the time yeah okay and uh in
2019 I decided to uh leave my job
because I was able toh sustain uh pay
myself and uh yeah anday all the deals
yeah and so you're doing flips in
addition to
this yeah well flips are more so like uh
for fun it's I do flips maybe two three
times a year
okay uh yeah just good pocket money okay
yeah you can probably live off your
flips and then your your other stuff
just generates income that's awesome
well done good for you well here's what
I figured out when I'm doing a flip I
buy something differently if I'm paying
cash and when it is paid for I am in no
rush to sell it so my yes my I I never
become a motivated seller or a motivated
buyer
and I get better deals on the buy and I
sell for higher on the sell because I
got all kinds of patience with no
payments but when the payment's eating
your eating your back pocket out it
makes you want to jump and get rid of
that thing you know what I'm
saying exactly and I I've been following
you for quite a while and uh I would
like to be debt free uh at some point uh
that's why uh have you got any
properties that are higher LTV that are
80 90%
TV uh no like uh usually when I when I
borrow it's really really low I mean
you're at about 50% on the portfolio
what you don't have any that are higher
than that they're all about
50% no not at all then then CU that that
would be the first ones I'd divest but
since you don't have those what I would
do is just look at the portfolio and go
okay 10 years from now which one of
these suckers do I want to
own and start going okay I'm going to
use something some cash flow and knock
out a few and I'm going to liquidate I
don't know couple million dollars worth
or million dollar million and a half
worth or whatever it comes out to be and
you know between those two things have a
two or threeyear plan to be free because
again you're going to have you're going
to be wealthier and you're going to have
a better life if you start with $4
million of paid for Real Estate three
years from
today I'm not arguing with that I think
I think he got a I think he got the nice
day version of that that was great well
he's he the reason is is cuz he's
actually pulling it off yeah he's not he
he could probably survive and not and do
and you know 10 years now you start
doing this nothing down real estate crap
on Tic Tac uh you're not going to
survive 10 years yeah because all the
guys that I knew doing that in any
generation have gone broke including meh
so uh but he's sitting in a 50% Equity
position so he's going to cash flow uh
and if he manages the property well and
he's been doing it a decade
already yeah so that tells me he he's
really got his crap together but now
we're down to the simple philosophy is
you start asking yourself is this
debt-free thing really better and the
actual end result of the data is yeah
you end up better not just a better
feeling you end up with more money well
yeah you laid that out really clearly I
think that he has a a good strategy for
him and something that he can start
walking towards which is really cool
yeah those of you that are playing with
real estate or want to play with real
estate let me just tell you something
you will never put in you will be less
likely never you can always do something
stupid you will be less likely to put a
bum tenant in a property when you don't
have any payments but when you got
payments you're looking for somebody to
pay those payments with their rent it's
a very and you're you're more desperate
as a landlord to fill your vacancies and
you're more likely to go well I know I
kind of had had a bad feeling turns out
she was doing drugs who knew but you
know I mean whatever it is right and you
put a a tenant in there that's a bum and
then you've got a mess they tear up the
place you go through you still go
through six months with no income you go
through an eviction you go through all
this stuff bankruptcies on them
everything else it's a mess but you
won't Overlook that if you're going I
don't think unless you really make me
feel good that I'm going to let you have
the privilege of living in my property
because I don't have any problems now
and I don't need you to bring your
problems to me that's such a good point
yeah so you just desperate landlords
make stupid decisions like desperate
people of any kind and it ends up
costing them more
yeah okay guys remember your first
investment property should be your
primary home after that's 100% paid off
and you've completed what I call baby
step six you'll be ready to start saving
to invest in additional properties in
other words you're completely dead free
house and everything you have a 3 to
6mon emergency fund you're also
investing at least 15% of your income
into retirement accounts and you can put
down 100% on an investment property
you're going to pay cash for it then
you're ready to get started I know
that's weird and I know that waiting
until you paid off your home probably
sounds like it takes forever especially
if an opportunity is knocking at your
door right now but trust me it's worth
it to wait until you're really ready you
won't have to take steps back for
penalty thanks for listening today make
sure to share this with a friend who you
think would enjoy it and don't miss the
last episode in the series where I talk
about why you should pay off your
mortgage as soon as
possible